we all knew it was going to happen
because all the signs were there but
it's now getting into overdrive
Trump allies are now reportedly raising
millions of dollars to pay to find
damaging information about journalists
who are seen as unfriendly to Donald
Trump and the Trump administration and
to then ideally use that information to
create antagonism campaigns against
journalists potentially to try to get
journalists fired certainly there will
be harassment from trumpets on the basis
of this opposition research campaign
against members of the Free Press that
Trump allies are undertaking and you you
can't miss the forest for the trees here
this is a hallmark of authoritarian
dictatorships this is a hallmark of
police states this is everything that is
the opposite of what the United States
is supposed to be this is Putin like
this is duterte like and we knew Trump
liked it we knew Trump liked going after
the media Trump going after specific
media outlets even specific journalists
in some cases the fake news moniker
applied very haphazardly not to fake
news but merely to anything that doesn't
say glowing effusive things about Donald
Trump and this is now an attempt to
formalize attacks on individual and
specific journalists these are attempts
in practice to silence or ruin the lives
of people who are reporting critically
about the President of the United States
one of the most important things that a
free and open press can do and should be
doing Axios has obtained the fundraising
pitch which has been deployed to get
people to donate to this cause the cause
that will ultimately gather information
that can be used to harass or discredit
journalists and reporters can you
imagine getting an email and being so
disconnected from reality
having your priorities or your morality
so backwards having such a fundamental
misunderstanding of what it is that is
important in the United States of
America when it comes to a free press
imagine getting an email saying we are
raising money to go after journalists
that are that are antagonizing
and saying you know what that sounds
like something I want to donate to and
apparently it isn't enough to just call
certain news outlets fake news and go
after them Trump's allies now want to go
after specific reporters one of the
people involved as a Republican
consultant named Arthur Schwartz the
primary targets of this campaign are
said to be and listen to this CNN and
MSNBC not surprising all of the
broadcast networks okay The New York
Times The Washington Post both of which
have been doing extraordinarily good
just plain old-fashioned investigative
work about this administration BuzzFeed
and The Huffington Post and this is the
kicker anyone else routinely included in
what a trump supporter sees as bias and
misinformation in their coverage of
Donald Trump meaning it could be anybody
I spoke to a couple of friends in
Washington DC who are not not
Republicans they're not directly
involved with this but they've been in
touch with people who have knowledge of
what's going on they told me independent
media journalists that are seen as
particularly antagonistic to the
president are not out of the realm of
possibility for being targeted and
harassed I am NOT this is not a delusion
of grandeur
where I think I am on Trump's radar or
on the list of people that this group is
going to come after I've merely been
told that it is not just corporate media
that is on the radar in terms of this
campaign so let's immediately put to
rest the Trump is talking point which
I've already seen floating around that
this is no big deal this is the same
thing Media Matters does Media Matters
criticizes and publishes media clips
they aren't going about trying to attack
and discredit individual reporters in
the way that is being suggested here
that Trump's allies want to do we've
seen this before and where we've seen
these attempts to harass and target
individual journalists it's places where
human rights have been decimated in any
number of ways Russia world war ii era
germany the philippines venezuela this
is if we
allow it to happen the normalization of
fascistic behavior it doesn't mean we
are a dictatorship but it is
authoritarian fascistic behavior attack
media as fake news treat them poorly
kick out individual journalists talk
about journalism licenses and lawsuits
against media and then smear campaigns
against individual journalists for being
journalists and doing their jobs this is
you know call it what you want is that
North Korea is that Stalin is that all
of them and a word by the way to the gun
nuts you know how the gun nuts say we
need guns to defend ourselves from a
government that becomes tyrannical this
is actually the type of thing that if
one believed the government would become
tyrannical would be sort of at the top
of the list starting to clamp down on a
free and independent press and yet I'm
not hearing from any of the gun nuts
that they're worried about this in fact
a lot of the trumpets gun nuts love this
because they fall in hook line & sinker
they've drank the kool-aid to borrow a
term from Jim Jones they've drank the
cooler not a term but an action I guess
they have drank the kool-aid on the
media is the enemy and we need to be
going after them rather than defending
them because it is a form of potential
government tyranny this is a form of
tyranny by special interest group to put
it another way but it happens to be one
that the gun nuts don't seem acutely
affected by in a way that makes them
realize oh man our threats our fears
about tyrannical government they're
actually not the kind that we really
need the guns to defend against but this
is starting to look like a form of
government tyranny understand that the
biggest threats to Trump's presidency
are the things that make the United
States what it is a Free Press is a
threat to donald trump's presidency
because he needs to hide the truth to
justify his reelection if people know
the truth there's no path to reelection
because his record is so atrocious high
voter turnout is a threat to donald
trump's presidency well we know why that
is trump benefits from people not voting
or not being able to vote this is real
this is happening now and it has to be
stopped in its tracks before it even
gets going make sure you're following me
on twitter at de Pakman let me know what
you think follow the show on twitter at
david pakman show and make
or to sign up if you have Amazon Prime
subscribe with twitch Prime at twitch.tv
slash David Pakman this is free for
everyone who has Amazon Prime but it
supports the work that we do twitch.tv
slash David Pakman I am thrilled to tell
you that today's episode is sponsored in
part by Blink accom slash Pakman blinka
is a really unique service for your
phone tablet and web browser and it is
incredibly useful for people like me who
love books and learning but are busy
blinka stakes the best and most popular
non-fiction books and condenses them
into 15-minute audiobooks i'm sure that
if you're like me you have a very long
list of books that you've been meaning
to read you only have so many hours in
the day and that's why blink astiz so
amazing they take the most important
information the themes the insights from
each book and they distill it into a 15
minute audio book that you can listen to
in one sitting I've listened to a ton of
books on blankets our audience can get a
7 day free trial by going to blink accom
slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube I've put a link in the
description I have listened to blinka
spokes about economics about political
science about history about science so
many interesting things and after the
free trial if you like it you can
continue enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about 5 bucks a month go
to blink is calm slash Pakman that's B
Li NK is t.com /pa ke ma n